As enterprises continue to look for new ways to innovate,
unlock the power of their data,
and create personalized customer experiences,
integration has become an obstacle to success.
Traditional approaches to integration simply can't keep up.
Organizations need to increase the speed of integration while lowering the cost.
To do this, a modern approach to integration is needed.
By adopting an agile integration strategy,
paired with IBM Cloud Pak for Integration,
you can support the scale, security,
and flexibility, required to power your digital transformation.
IBM Cloud Pak for Integration
can be deployed on premises or on any public or private cloud environment
by leveraging Red Hat OpenShift,
allowing your team to innovate and scale in a sandbox
without putting your existing infrastructure at risk.
Learn, innovate, and scale at your own pace while continuing leverage your existing investments.
IBM Cloud Pak for Integration leverages the right mix of integration capabilities
to balance traditional and modern integration styles.
Simplify the management of your integration architecture
and integrate 3 times faster,
while reducing the cost of integration by one third.
Let's start by logging into IBM Cloud Pak for Integration.
As you can see, a single login provides you with access to all of  the integration tools your team needs in one unified experience.
In the sidebar are all of the capabilities.
Let's take a quick look at each.
We'll start with API lifecycle,
which allows you to create, secure, manage, share, and monetize API's across all of your cloud environments
using the built-in developer portal.
A robust API strategy is a key component
to any modern integration strategy.
Take control of your API ecosystem and scale integration.
The next capability is application integration.
From the simplest Software as a Solution application,
to the most complex on-premises systems,
your team can use a  broad range of pre-built connectors
to quickly integrate data and applications  without worrying about mismatched sources formats or standards.
Our enterprise messaging capability is a security-rich messaging solution,
developed through our years of
experience with IBM MQ,
trusted by some of the world's most successful enterprises.
Simplify and facilitate the exchange of data
while ensuring that each message is sent and received only once.
No modern hybrid integration platform is complete without event streaming,
which uses Apache Kafka to allow you to not only send messages easily and reliably,
but also to react to events in real time,
enabling you to provide your customers with more personalized experiences.
Our high-speed data transfer is truly unique.
Send, share, stream, and sync large data sets virtually anywhere,
reliably and at maximum speed across global IP networks.
Accelerate collaboration and meet the
demands of complex global teams
without compromising performance or security.
The secure gateway found in IBM Cloud Pak for Integration
provides organizations with a single multi-channel gateway
to meet the security and integration needs of today's digital business.
While being able to access all of the integration styles your team needs from a single interface is great,
there are also some additional benefits to this unified experience,
including common logging and an asset repository.
the common logging feature found in IBM Cloud Pak for Integration
allows you to search and visualize log entries across your entire integration environment.
You can find logging links for every individual instance
in both the header and instance lists.
These links launch Kibana with predefined filters for each capability.
The asset repository is a centralized hub,
allowing teams on IBM Cloud Pak for Integration to work collaboratively
- sharing and reusing resources
to save time and improve efficiency.
While we've briefly touched on some of the most important features and capabilities
of IBM Cloud Pak for Integration,
the value really becomes clear
when you see the power of using some of these capabilities together.
The improvements in your team's work flow and efficiency through IBM Cloud Pak for Integration,
combined with the benefits of an agile
integration strategy,
will enable your business to support a modern, agile approach to integration
and keep up with the increasing demand for integration.
Thank you for watching.
Take the next step on your cloud journey by visiting our website.